[Music]
River babes
after a mini break we're back and I'm so
happy to see you welcome to our
Sweetwater secrets preview show for
chapter 313 chapter 48 requiem for a
welterweight wow that is a mouthful I'm
going to keep messing it up let's make a
game of it shall we
and before we dive all into it who do
you think I'm channeling today tell me
in the comments
now today I'll be bringing you something
very special and exclusive sneak peek
scene from episode 313 plus I'm
releasing new interviews with Cole
Sprouse and Lily Reinhart who are
weighing in on some of Riverdale's
romances plus I'm dropping three clues
about episode 313 and of course
answering a round of your live questions
aka my favorite part but first you all
know the drill let's take a look back at
your hisses kisses comments and theories
from our Sweetwater secrets after-show
for episode 312 because I don't know
about you but I need a refresher on
where we left off so let's go first up
hejdå ask i'm really wants to live in
bizarro Dale because she said this is
the first episode i've loved in such a
long time it was smooth and had a
perfect balance with all the characters
I will say I would have loved a - more
bug head but other than that I thought
3:12 was just delicious and so did the
Simpsons show no not the cartoon the
YouTube commenter ro best episode ever
Cheryl said she's a lesbian Tony found
her voice Josie stole my heart Cheryl
righted her wrongs and these interviews
with van and ash are delightful thank
you so much you know I was so thrilled
to be the one to debut the new pretty
poisons jackets for you but it seems
like the fans are split on how to feel
about this new girl gang so misty Rose
Blackthorne posted I can't wait to see
more show knee and pretty poisons but
then hey you
Nomi countered and said hisses - pretty
poisons like how many gangs are there
supposed to be in small town I feel like
the new gang will kind of ruin the image
- the serpents for the viewers
interesting and yes I will say that
there are a lot of gangs in one small
town but it seems like there is one
thing that all show me fans can agree on
though now Julia Gomez commented kisses
to Tony for making Cheryl realize that
what she did was wrong and their first
fight was constructive and healthy I
agree but moving on Adriana Potts made a
great point and posted hisses - the fact
that Riverdale has a costume store that
sells realistic gargoyle king costumes
where is everyone getting them from I
know I know I know you know we all know
this is getting ridiculous now at this
point I honestly don't even care who the
gargoyle king is you faked me out twice
I'm done
so witching over to shipper scoop though
less Z commented I'm kind of starting to
ship Josie in Archie just because of the
way he said can I kiss you I know right
consent is so sexy you guys but it seems
like others are still warming up to the
idea of our chose e because megan khun
quipped the only question is who hasn't
archie kissed fair fair but i wanted to
know how you river rates are feeling
about this new potential pairing so i
called up for a vote on e t--'s YouTube
channel and more than 20,000 of you
voted in our biggest poll yet so I asked
what do you think about Josie and Archie
and 15 percent said I love them I'm
excited to see where this ship sails
seventeen percent answered not a fan I
prefer barchi nine percent voted and
said I'm holding out for barchi while
whopping 59 percent picked sheesh Archie
try being single for a minute that was
my favorite one I voted for that too
now I also wanted to get another opinion
so here's what Lilly Reinhardt thinks
about Archie's love life this season
I don't know I feel like Archie should
be alone for like a second yeah but
something that our show does pay tribute
to the original comics is that Archie
really does kind of go from woman to
woman and we do it in a very subtle way
or Roberto does and our writers do but
Archie does get around he's been with
almost everyone and it's like that's
just kind of our homage to the comics
Lily's honesty
now our Josie feels fast but so does
edgy so at this point I'm just watching
the ships sail by yeah but now let's
switch gears into what we can expect
from this week's episode because I'm
very excited I am going to debut an
exclusive sneak peak scene from episode
3 13-feet read Jughead and Tony and
y'all it's pretty tense take a look
topaz being in the Serpent's is your
birthright we are a family I'd like you
to reconsider joining the gang and you
want me back in the Serpent's make me
Queen I mean since I'm like a sea and
all right you know I can't do that Tommy
because of Betty right then I'm not
coming back what are the pretty poisons
providing for you that the servants
can't an opportunity to lead with the
pretty poisons I roll we're a sisterhood
you're Cheryl's vanity project you mean
and you're wrong about the Serpent's
still being a family that's how it used
to be not any more issues about to go
down now how are you feeling about this
tension between Jughead and Tony tell me
in the comments right now I'm not here
for it but I understand it's expected
but let's dive right now into my three
clues about chapter 48 wreck we requiem
for a welterweight hate it you guys hate
it huh
number one one couple heats up another
cools down and one is completely mi a
number two they may look pretty but
their actions might poison the way you
feel about them and number three before
you can say I do to the farm you'll need
something old something new something
borrowed and something blue and I'll be
explaining that clue fully in the after
show so get ready one more of course you
do
well now that Gladys and jellybean are
sticking in town for a while
I asked Cole Sprouse to spill the Jones
family tea and if he's more of a phallus
or flatus shipper take a look at what he
told me I'm excited that the Jones
family sticking around episode 12 coming
back into town they come back what you
guys doing here what is that family
dynamic like when they're all back
together in Riverdale I think the first
meeting between all of them is quite
cautious
I know FP is very cautious and I know
Jughead wants to be excited but
definitely is thinking twice and then I
think as time goes on Gladys and
jellybean sort of reveal their true
intentions which end up being quite
devilish as well I think it's
interesting as Jughead has such a strong
moral Center about doing wrong and I
think Gladys's is sort of resigned to
the idea of wrongness within her life so
she's very willing to step on people if
it means getting what she wants
I think she's trying to impart on
Jughead as a tactician do you think the
drug had would want his parents to get
back together or do you think that he
wants his girlfriend's mom to date his
dad I don't know I don't even know if he
knows about Allison FP that's true I
don't think we've ever addressed fit not
with them in the room I don't think
there's ever been a scene where they've
sat down and gone like we're canoodling
people so I don't think he even knows
about that but I certainly think there's
a part of Jughead that's quite a
nostalgic and that yearns for this
family relationship that he didn't ever
really have so I think you want somebody
get back together what do you think the
babes are you intrigued to see if FP and
Allyce get back together or are you a
ride-or-die valise shipper sharing me
your share me your thoughts tell me your
thoughts it's early you guys uh and now
it's time for my favorite part of these
live preview shows answering your
questions which I've never seen before
so let's take a look once again was
there flooding the comment section I
heard that there were so many gasp
emojis during the Tony
Jughead scene so I was shocked too when
I watched it and that they let me reveal
it for you guys let's see they all say
you're channeling Alice well done guys
yes I am dressed in white today I've got
my charms I've got my stones I'm ready
to be baptized into the farm no I'm not
that place is crazy
first up NAT says Archie leave your lips
dry focus on getting your sad life
together and then you may date do I
agree that he needs to take a minute and
find wholeness yes when I say it's sad
no he's been through a lot and he's
dealing with it in his own ways and
we'll see that in tonight's episode he's
really channeling a lot of his energy
into boxing but if you watch our
after-show tomorrow it is featured in my
hisses and kisses I'm not gonna tell you
which one but I'm sure you can guess
next up blog says barchi ship name is
way better than our Josie and don't get
me started on veggie okay I'm never a
big fan of
on couples for their shift names they
can't help it
for what their ship names are like and
if TV creators are now creating names in
order to have them make cool ship names
like that's really going too far
our chose e I think we're just not used
to it
Benji I think is amazing cuz it's like
veggies I like it when it sounds like
something barchi once again like that's
another one where maybe you think it's
weird but I think we're just used to it
by now judging people in their ship
names is weird a lot of people hate on
phallus because we've talked about this
before I like it it's that's their names
just deal with it
okay moving on we have so many comments
let's go away back to the beginning
Nikki Cole's I would love to see jug
propose to Betty bug head is endgame
we've talked about this in the past on
previous preview shows I love young love
I believe in endgame I believe in
soulmates do I believe that you need to
get married right out of high school not
my Jam's but hey love is love
elegant maddie says any more special
episodes except the musical nothing that
I've heard of so far I think they're
gearing up to maybe introduce Katy keen
um that could be something they might be
doing kind of like a spin-off backdoor
pilot so that's just me speculating I'm
really excited for the musical episode
though so I'm happy to focus all my
special episode energy onto that one
Dawn of the Dead pre hisses to Jughead
if he believes GLaDOS or jelly bean over
Betty yes now for all of you fans you
might be able to piece together that the
last time that I was on the Riverdale
set was actually for this episode so
GLaDOS and Betty have yet to meet as of
when I was doing all of my interviews
but I still have plenty of scoop on that
subject coming forward so we're moving
forward scuse me
let's see Kaitlyn says I want more bug
head I do not care
no new gang no hate yes and then vlog
says will veronica be in the new game
mmm I highly doubt Veronica will be in
the new game she
too busy trying to get involved in her
parents lives and run the lodge family
Empire I have no idea what's going on
with Veronica anymore and I'm kind of
tired of it but yes I agree I would like
more bug-head
I feel like there's more hoz in these
like past two episodes than there has
been a bug head this entire season which
we've talked about before that they're
doing really great and it's nice to know
that they're in a solid place but I
think it's time that we get a little bug
head yeah let's see
Kelsi Betty's not legacy because Alice
left the serpents and how wasn't a
serpent this is true oh I don't know if
it's necessarily true that he is still a
bit of a serpent legacy but as much as
Tony is a lot is a legacy probably not
Tony I feel probably rightfully that's
that queen crown I think does belong to
her
just by line of succession I've been
watching a lot of Game of Thrones so
Molly do Shoni have an argument again
because that broke my heart but I was so
happy it was a healthy argument we are
gonna keep seeing a little bit more
growing pains for Shoni which I once
again like to see different sides of
relationships I like to see when couples
call each other out when they're doing
something crazy and if that means that
tony is finally starting to get her
spunk back that she had me first met her
I'm all for it Vanessa and I have talked
about this and you'll see it more on the
after show that she misses the way that
Tony was when we were first introduced
to her she loves Cheryl obviously but
I'm excited to personally get to see
Tony regain a bit more of that
confidence that she had when we first
met her Selah says do we meet Edgar
tonight I will not comment on that but I
will say that if you tuned in to the
after-show
there will be scoop
Raymond says Archie needs to focus on
his studies and other things instead of
going around to get with almost every
girl he's been in the struggle for so
long since the Hiram thing and needs to
be alone
I completely agree I agree he's kissed a
lot of girls which as Lily just said and
you saw in our interview that's kind of
their nod to the comics because in the
original comments Archie he's a sweet
guy but yes he did kind of get with
every single pairing and let's go
through them all together shall we and
you tell me if I'm missing anyone he's
kiss Betty he's kissed Veronica he's
kissed Josie he's Sheryl he's kissed a
farm floozy he's kissed Valerie from the
Pussycats I feel like I'm missing
someone I'm up to six comment and tell
me who I'm missing
let's see handle says kind of think
Jughead is being unfair like Tony's been
there from the start and Betty is just
in the surface cuz jugheads in the
serpent's I don't think she cares I
think that he does care because she
wants to be there for her Jughead and
that she's Lili has told me that Betty
likes to stand by her man and that she's
excited to be there and she's excited to
support him but I do think that I miss
Tony in the serpents and I'll have more
scoop from Vanessa about that in the
after-show I'm kind of talking about
Tony's headspace after this episode cuz
a lot it happens I'm so excited for you
guys to see it a lot happens and there's
a lot that we're gonna be discussing and
I don't know how you guys are gonna feel
about pretty poisons after we watched
this episode Isis says can you explain
the part where Josie leaves for New York
I'm so confused with that so I don't
know much about it just yet but I do
know that the lovely Ashley Murray is
gonna be going to the new potential
Riverdale spin-off now keep in mind guys
this is not official the spin-off is
gonna be called Katie Keene and it's
kind of like a it's kind of like the way
I'm thinking of it in my head is it's a
Gossip Girl musical because it takes
place in New York and it's like I'm
thinking it's like did you guys watch
Glee when Rachel went to New York for
that later half of it that's kind of
what I'm envisioning it's gonna be very
sexy it's gonna be very competitive and
but the whole thing is that CW has to
pick up the show so the way it works I'm
not sure if you guys are super familiar
with the way that the TV process works
but
right now they are gonna film a pilot
which is a first episode for Katie Keene
and then if the CW likes it then they
pick up the show and then we'll be
getting a certain batch of episodes next
fall so if the show does get picked up
and it does move forward then Josie
McCoy will be a part of that series I'm
not sure how she'll be leaving Riverdale
but I do know that we are having a
interview with mama McCoy and it's live
on ETS YouTube page today and she's
talking about whether or not mama and
McCoy will be going with her as well so
keep an eye out for that keep it locked
to my Twitter page I'll be tweeting that
out um okay
oh I forgot Grundy thanks guys
Archie kissed Grundy oh how could I
forget about that I know how I could
forget about that because I hated it and
I wanted it out of my brain Oh
Grundy um never Grundy everyone she died
not like excited for someone to die but
that was good death that was a good
death I'd be excited if Hiram died it
was like a good death but I don't know
if we'll ever get that Ashley Toni
deserves respect and status but Betty is
jugheads Queen that's a good way to put
it
I like that Toni deserves respect
Betty's jugheads Queen Christy do they
have a sexual health clinic in Riverdale
the residents might need one fair point
fair point maybe they'll open one in the
bunker and also like more and more
people are discovering this bunker and
it's supposed to be really hidden in the
middle of the woods but you'll see like
in upcoming episodes oh hi random person
I've never met before meet me in this
bunker how are these people like
wandering through the woods and finding
this mysterious bunker I find it
hilarious
let's see lots of folks want more of
Toni's backstory and family angle same I
want it Vanessa wants it so many people
want to know more about Toni
it's kind of like she's just like popped
out of nowhere and she's awesome and
then kind of got adapted into Cheryl's
life but and we know a little bit of
that she used to live with her uncle and
then he was awful but yes I would love
to meet Tony's mom Hugh machen we don't
know what happened to her so she could
still be out there
I'd like to think that she and Gladys
are friends
um we are gonna just take a few more
actually bit time
Ashley says the Serpent's need a council
made of jug Tony
Betty Sweet Pea fangs and Cheryl I don't
know if they need to council but they
all need to have a meeting after
tonight's episode because they need to
hash it out things happen and I am upset
these people want peaches and cream I
want peaches and cream too
coming up in a few more episodes I think
we'll finally get our peaches and cream
introduction I was hoping to get it a
little earlier but still waiting but I
love the name I've heard she's a
kick-butt character I'm here for it Anna
Betty deserves to be the snake Queen but
she needs to solve her family problems
now Betty has her hands full
goodness gracious the things that happen
in this week's episode will make your
head spin and have you gasping for air
that's all I'm going to say you guys
have seen the trailer you can put the
two and two together um let's see what
else we got
let's see handle a lot of people think
the drug that's been impaired Neeley do
you think Shoni would win or bug-head
would win in a fight I'm not gonna
answer that they shouldn't fight I think
that Shoni would win because Jughead
wouldn't hit a girl
Molly do or he hit her penny Peabody she
was the worst
interesting what do you guys think would
win I don't want to put them against
each other I like them too much
Betty seems scrappy this is gonna I'm
gonna be thinking about this all day
Milly will we meet Tony's family see
before let's see we are gonna go way way
way back
NAB Joseph being good for Tony standing
up for herself and her beliefs we will
be seeing more of that charlie Cynthia I
hope everything's going good for Sweet
Pea and things and Tony
that's all I'm saying that's all it's
through the same base that it make
whenever I think of Kevin I love Kevin
Betty has everything Tony wants a
serpent Kingdom and a beautiful king who
could be fully over Jughead I'm not sure
about that one but Tony likes Cheryl
okay Rick says how is no one talking
about the mevin breakup Oh Rick okay
let's talk about the mevin breakup how
are you guys feeling about the Mebane
breakup I hate it because it hurt
Kevin's heart but I'm excited because I
although moose went through a lot and it
wasn't fair to say that I wish he'd come
out sooner and and been more open with
Kevin's relationship because everyone
comes out in their own timeline I'm
never judging anyone for that but I'm
just saying hearing Kevin talked to
Cheryl and say maybe if he loved me more
he'd feel comfortable doing that just
broke my heart I feel like it was not a
good relationship for him to be in I
felt like he was constantly just trying
to get moose to care about him and love
him enough to like come out to his dad
and be proud to be with him and I feel
like that kind of mentally whooped him
for a little bit so I love Kevin Keller
he deserves the moon and so find someone
who gets him the moon get him the moon
guys Nadia I want to know who's giving
out all these gargoyle asks and costumes
man they must have a killer costume
store in Riverdale it is amazing because
how are they getting all these random
masks do you think they have Amazon or
actually since it's Riverdale and
everything slightly off like tonight
you're going to hear about 23 hour
fitness what would we call Amazon
instead rainforest I don't know honey
do we get the origins of the girls in
pretty poisons hopefully hopefully as of
right now they're just kind of they're
kind of 50s like that's all
people are really hurt by the mevin
breakup oh you guys I know now are you
are you hurt because you love Kevin
Keller just as much as I do or because
you actually loved them together as a
couple and I loved that we all decided
on mevin the show kept calling it coos
which was never my fan but we all voted
at the beginning of the sweetwater
secret season y'all picked lovin so here
we are just a few more questions Nadia
says oh no Kaitlyn says anyone who goes
in that bunker better not sit on the bed
if they do they need to bring clean
sheets
I do hope that mevin took Cheryl's
advice and brought clean sheets to the
bunker that's all I'm gonna say because
goodness gracious and how are we feeling
about our chose II do all of you guys
who out there is shipping them into NY
tell me that right now vici says I don't
want Tony to move on so fast
she's a serpent by blood I mean she said
it herself yes and I think that although
this was really really sweet that Sheryl
created this girl gang for Tony I think
that you will start to see that this
gift it maybe not be what it seems to be
it may not be as heartfelt
as it was initially and it's really sad
to watch I'm Tristan I think by the end
of the season Tony will be given her
rightful place as serpent Queen and
Cheryl will stay with the pretty poisons
and there will be an alliance love that
idea I know nothing about this but
Tristan I love that idea
yes I'm here for that because I still
want the Serpent's to be the Serpent's
to be part of the Riverdale lore I love
it I have three serpent jackets at this
point so which I love we have this one
right here with the black one of my red
one and I have a vest so if they get rid
of the serpents well then I have to go
shopping and I think we'll end it there
now thank you all so much for watching
today's live preview and be sure to
check back with me after you've watched
chapter xlviii requiem for a
welterweight for our Sweetwater secrets
after-show plus exclusive scoop Lily
Reinhart and Vanessa Morgan spilling
answers on your biggest
Christiane's but for now hit the
comments and tell me what you think is
gonna happen in episode 313 are you
ready to discover more about the farm
which couple needs to step up their game
and who else is totally over the
gargoyle King tell me everything and
I'll see you after the episode river
babes bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]